[Music]
across the infinite cosmos of the video
game no man's sky
there are a similarly infinite number of
alien life forms
through the use of procedural generation
the game contains more than 18
quintillion planets to discover many of
which team with extraordinary creatures
while no man's sky had a rocky reception
at launch the developers have done
persistent work making this virtual
universe worth exploring
so for this entry into the archive
we'll embark on a classic documentary
style expedition
exploring the lives of extraterrestrials
on scorching worlds frozen wastelands
and many others i'll also speculate on
how the biology of each life form might
feasibly work i admit that there are a
few too many total planets for this
archivist to document so this
documentary will focus on only the most
interesting ones i've discovered
now let's head off into the unknown and
see what awaits us among the stars
we'll begin with an earth-like temperate
world located a comfortable distance
from its host star
since we are the first explorers to ever
witness this planet it's up to us to
come up with a name we'll call this ring
jewel of the cosmos planet rhea a land
abundant with the promise of discovery
entering the atmosphere near the equator
we can see a vast landscape of green
fields stretching before us under the
orbiting rings above who knows what
extraterrestrial life has emerged
stepping out of the spacecraft i spot
something moving in the distance a herd
of herbivorous giants are grazing on the
local vegetation
these newly discovered creatures also
need a name we'll call them titano
magnus magnificus which might be a bit
much but i'm excited the titano magnus
seem to have converged upon a niche
similar to sauropod dinosaurs from
earth's past they survive by being too
large for most predators to bother with
and sustain their bulk by vacuuming up
over one ton of plant matter each day
with their long necks and curious ears
the titano magnus actually resemble
another earth animal the giraffe a life
form whose long neck helps them reach
leaves at the tops of trees yet there
are no trees in this region of planet
rhea so why bother with such a long neck
perhaps a tree like genus recently went
extinct or perhaps the necks serve as
watchtowers to keep an eye out for
potential dangers
and speaking of potential dangers a huge
armored predator is on the move i'll
call these unfriendly customers the
arachnomantis because well i can the
arachnomantis possess a bone-crushing
beak and seem to have some kind of
exoskeleton the biological differences
between the arachnomantis and
titanomagnus seem so extreme i wonder if
like land vertebrates and insects here
on earth these two terrestrial lineages
split off long before crawling onto land
yet unlike insects the arachnomantis are
megafauna in their own right and a
serious danger upon these planes
with our different evolutionary origins
it's likely i wouldn't be very tasty to
an arachnomantis but it's best not to
test that theory
for the next leg of our voyage across
planet rhea will be traveling in a
terrestrial exocraft called a roamer
this vehicle will offer protection as we
continue to explore this unfamiliar land
plus it's nice to not have to walk for
the entire voyage
not far from our roamer something is
disturbing the grass
this is a crested railope these
diminutive grazers are difficult to get
a glimpse of as they've learned their
best chance of survival in this world of
giants is to stay out of sight their
skittish behavior likens them to the
antelopes of the grasslands here on
earth we're lucky to be able to get a
sighting of such a shy creature
but railopes aren't the only things
hiding in the grass even more elusive
are the shadowy striped dread tooth
these cat-like hunters are exceedingly
difficult to spot
like tigers their unique pattern of
stripes help them blend into their
environment and the spines on their back
help them disappear even further and
this dread tooth has caught the scent of
something typically dread tooth feed
only on rayalopes and the youngest of
titano magnus but this dread tooth has
its sights on an adult we might have a
serious fight on our hands the dread
tooth circles in close
then seems to think better of it a
full-grown titanomagness isn't exactly
an easy target it's just not worth the
risk and so the dreadtooth returns to
the prowl looking for something a little
smaller to snack on
the sun is now setting on planet rhea
yet with the night comes a final
surprise the arachnomantis while a
fearsome predator during the daylight
lights up the dark with a bioluminescent
display as it calls out to others of its
kind this ritual which might be for
mating purposes is a touching one for
such a deadly creature we've seen much
during our travels across planet rhea
but now the stars call us once again
this world is just one of many and the
moment has come to continue our
expedition
the next stop on our voyage planet
bereas lies on the outer edge of its
star's habitable zone
entering the atmosphere i find a land
trapped in a never-ending winter berea's
position combined with a dim host star
means temperature on the surface rarely
rises above freezing
and a layer of snow and ice covers the
surface year round it's not the sort of
place one might expect to find life
yet life is here all the same this is a
snow snuffler a life form perfectly
adapted for a sub-zero lifestyle
large lumbering herbivores they're
protected from the cold thanks to a
thick layer of fat and insulating fur
wrapping oneself in the biological
equivalent of a thick winter coat is one
of the most common ways that animals
here on earth have been able to conquer
cold environments
so it makes sense the snow snufflers
would have a convergent tactic for
staying warm but surviving the elements
is only half the battle to persist on
planet bereas the snow snufflers must
also find food
luckily this is something the snow
snuffler is quite good at their
sensitive trunks are equipped with scent
receptors powerful enough to locate the
subterranean vegetation the snow
snufflers feed upon so the snow
snufflers have sniffed their way into an
enviable spot on the food web
but there's more than one way to survive
on a planet of ice horned chillmanders
are scaly creatures that aren't as well
insulated from the cold and aren't as
proficient at sniffing out food instead
they have a different strategy to
confront the low temperatures
hibernation
on earth numerous animals hibernate
during winter months slowing their
metabolic rate to conserve energy only
to emerge again when food is more
abundant on planet bereas however
temperatures drop without warning year
round which is why the chillmanders are
capable of slowing their metabolic rate
multiple times per year these lethargic
life forms spend most of their time
basking in the sun expending precious
little energy even when not hibernating
it's a lifestyle i'm a bit jealous of
even if it's not the most exciting
yet where there are herbivores
particularly abundant slow moving ones
there are invariably carnivores lumber
moths are tall somewhat awkward looking
predators that spend most of their time
reared up on their hind legs to
intimidate rivals and survey the
landscape while they are the dominant
predators of this region lumber moths
aren't particularly aggressive
like many species of bears they are
hypocarnivorous meaning their diet
consists mainly of fungi berries in
other plant materials rather than meat
after all on a planet as harsh as bereas
being picky just isn't practical i'm not
entirely certain if they'd like the
taste of me so i'll give them some
personal space planet bereas is an
extreme and fascinating world but the
time has come to continue our voyage
our next galactic destination is planet
nehrus home to an incredible planet-wide
ocean
entering the atmosphere i find that only
a few small islands break up the endless
expanse of water most life on planet
nehrus is likely waiting under the waves
yet touching down on one of the larger
islands i find some intrepid species
have come ashore at the water's edge i
spot a coastal shell swimmer amphibious
herbivores shell swimmers feed off
marine plants that grow in the shallows
just beyond the shore it's a lifestyle
similar to the marine iguanas of the
galapagos islands which likewise spend
most of their life span in the
intertidal zone on planet nehrus even
land dwellers are tied to the sea
elsewhere on the island the bizarre glow
horns feed on coastal swamp grass in
appearance and behavior glow horns are
convergent with hoofed ruminant mammals
like deer yet when night falls these
lifeforms reveal a side that is all
their own bioluminescent display
structures on their back light up
creating a dazzling display that helps
the glow horns find potential mates in
the darkness it's a mesmerizing
spectacle to see in person
yet the light of glow horns can attract
more than potential mates it can also
attract predators and on the island
coast no predator is more dangerous than
the terror beak these t-rex like
creatures are huge towering over all
other land animals on these islands it
might seem surprising to see large
creatures in an isolated ecosystem yet
this is actually an example of island
gigantism a trend that exists on earth
as well in species like komodo dragons
island gigantism is a biological
phenomenon in which a species on an
island increases dramatically in size
for the terabeaks their massive bulk
allows them to feed on any species they
wish
yet land animals only make up a small
percentage of life on nehru's diving
under the waves i find a much denser
ecosystem awaits the first life forms i
spot are the inquisitive tentacled
cephalophores that move in sporadic
patterns in accordance to the ocean
currents cephalophores travel in groups
perhaps for protection or perhaps
because they just like the company their
soft bodies and manipulatory tentacles
resemble those of an octopus and like
octopuses they're quite intelligent
exactly how intelligent is difficult to
measure but they show an acute sense of
curiosity circling around me as i swim
by i wonder if perhaps the cephalophores
feel they are studying me
the bulk of underwater species within
the planet-wide ocean are fast-moving
fish-like life-forms we'll call silver
fins they gather in schools that number
in the thousands much like the true fish
of our oceans and with such high numbers
silver fins are an appealing food source
for aquatic predators
in one such predator is lurking below
this silent streamlined hunter is a
saltwater reef stalker the premier
hunter of this global ocean reef
stalkers are significantly faster than
their preferred prey using their
muscular tail to propel themselves
through the water their torpedo-like
body plan mirrors that of most sharks as
does their killer appetite in these
bountiful waters every day is a feast
yet fortunately like earth sharks this
reef stalker ultimately isn't that
interested in taking a bite out of me
all the same i'd feel safer with some
extra protection to explore the deepest
region of this global ocean i'm
traveling in an aquatic exocraft called
anatolon
at the bottom of the largest trench on
planet nehrus something mysterious is
waiting a bright light emanates from the
eye of a strange organism growing from a
wall exiting my submarine i move in
closer only to be caught in a hypnotic
vortex of light it takes all my strength
to break away
that was an abyssal horror a lifeform
that calls to prey with a bioluminescent
lure much like an earth anglerfish
i suddenly feel that i've seen enough of
planet nerus
racing along through the stars i find my
ship is low on fuel
fortunately i know just the place to get
some more this strange geometric
construction is a space station a common
sight in this part of the cosmos they
function almost like intergalactic truck
stops and are open to all kinds of
space-faring life
as our ship enters the space station
through the main aperture the automatic
guiding system takes over and we're
ushered towards the first available
landing pad after so much time exploring
the cosmic wilds it's a strange
sensation to return to an artificial
environment yet we need fuel to continue
our expedition so we might as well relax
this station is run by the diminutive
geck one of the primary sentient species
in this region of space they're
organized and rather pragmatic beings
more interested in practical matters
than conversation
while i'd like to know more about the
specifics of their biology i've yet to
meet a gek comfortable with discussing
that topic so i won't press it all sorts
of different species pass through this
particular station
some like the mysterious corvax appear
to be entirely artificial how these
inorganic life forms function is of
particular interest but like the geck
they aren't keen on sharing secrets
still just being in the presence of
other intelligent life forms some of
which are likely explorers themselves is
a special privilege but with the ship
refueled the time is right to return to
our voyage
the second to last planet we'll be
visiting is the most extreme so far
planet helios orbits extremely close to
its star making it a world of blistering
temperatures
entering the atmosphere a sun-scorched
landscape of ash and smoke awaits
only a few barren plants are able to
take root in this infernal biosphere
i don't expect to find much life here
but life is nothing if not stubborn a
few persistent organisms have risen to
the challenge the most tenacious
creatures we'll call igneo beasts
forms with a curious defense against the
heat like the sea pangolins of the
indian ocean they incorporate mineral
sulfides into their hide like a kind of
fire resistant second skin
allowing igneobeast to survive in this
volcanic wasteland igneous beasts are
also excellent tunnelers allowing them
to dig for edible roots and underground
aquifers it's an extreme life but a life
all the same
and speaking of extreme
[Music]
that was a heliostrider a titanic
lifeform with a body plan unlike any
organism i've ever come across their
alarming height means that helio
striders pay little mind to anything on
this planet's surface like igneo beasts
these omnivores feed primarily on buried
plant matter sticking their heads
underground to get a meal it's a
somewhat awkward behavior that calls to
mind how ostriches look when burying
their eggs
like most life forms on planet helios
the skin of the heliostrider seems
highly resistant to the merciless solar
radiation in fact the helio striders are
practically thriving
but not all creatures on planet helios
are quite so fortunate
crag spines are mid-sized scavengers
that struggle to find sustenance in this
barren environment at a glance they
resemble the savannah foxes of our
planet although the niche they occupy is
less enviable
crag spines live short sweaty lives
under the uncaring sun rarely getting
enough food to stave off hunger a harsh
existence for a harsh world planet
helios has shown us the incredible
tenacity of life but now let's head to
our final planet
at the end of our journey through the
stars the massive mysterious planet
erebuzz awaits from our current position
it's impossible to tell what the surface
looks like entering the atmosphere and
flying below the clouds i discover a
hidden paradise is waiting with a
temperate climate in abundant vegetation
planet erebuzz is a place where
evolution is free to experiment like
never before
and here is one such experiment now
my goodness
this is a well it's difficult to think
of a name i'll call them
george
the georges appear to be herbivores with
mouths located on the underside of their
bodies to feed georges simply move
across the rich carpet of vegetation
that covers the planet essentially
functioning like living lawn mowers
their system of locomotion is comparable
to terrestrial snails which slowly
propel themselves using waves of
muscular contractions
dozens of primitive eyes cover the front
end of the georges which might seem like
overkill yet certain types of scallops
on our own planet are known to have an
even higher total eye count it's easy to
dismiss the georges as some sort of
biological misadventure yet all forms of
life no matter how bizarre or their own
sort of miracle
in the skies above planet arabs
something remarkable is passing overhead
these are aereoderms of remarkable form
of floating life they're held aloft by
some kind of internal gas bladder their
trunks aren't quite as impressive as
those of an elephant and are perhaps
more analogous to the schwart prehensile
noses of tapers yet erioderms can feed
on the tops of trees as their buoyant
bodies mean nothing is out of reach
for the last leg of my journey across
planet erebuzz i'll be using a special
research vehicle
this exocraft is called a minotaur a
robust mechanical walker that allows me
to travel further and stay safer
and it seems that extra precautions
weren't a mistake a horrifying mass of
tentacles burst from the ground grasping
at the air close to me this subterranean
terror cannot be seen in full so i'll
simply call them nightmares
without being able to see the rest of
these life forms it is impossible to
determine their exact biology but they
seem to be ambush predators that burrow
under their targets and attack from
below even a paradise like erebuzz can
be a dangerous place to linger
yet with the night a deep calm settles
over this normally restless planet it is
a bittersweet feeling to know our voyage
is complete but the time has come to
head for home
yet of course no man's sky is a game
without end beyond each horizon is
another one with every planet just a
fleeting waypoint in a voyage without a
destination
there's a certain melancholy that the
game can evoke as the sheer size of the
universe creeps into one's mind no
matter how long you spend in this
universe on a cosmic scale there is only
so much a single entity can do and see
i think the team behind this project
have done an admirable job expanding
this procedural universe and i'm excited
to know what comes next
and as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious
see you in the next video
you